let's find uh more out more about the
situation on the ground today with the
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell Sean
great to see you as as always let's
start in on the East and what's the
latest situation there well bill harifka
has been their big news today uh
devastating uh attack on the school
there
um lots of locals were using it for
shelter apparently 90 people 30 have got
out two look like they've died 60
unknown at the moment they're given the
devastation up there it doesn't look
good for the rest of them and pop Asner
is the other said he's shown here to the
west of luhansk the Russians have taken
that City the Ukrainian reports that
their city was absolutely devastating
it's just another example of the Russian
approach to flattening the cities as
they go let's touch on that approach and
the way that some of these places have
uh have been flattened why are the
Russians doing that is it intentional is
it because the weapons aren't targeted
enough yeah I think the West has been
shocked at the Russian approach to um to
this war particularly they're fighting a
sort of 20th century war in the 21 first
century using unguided missiles unguided
bombs unguided artillery and that's an
inevitable result is you end up with
devastation let's give you an example of
a thousand pound bomb that's been the
staple diet of most military Air Forces
for the last hundred years in unguided
form delivered largely follows a
ballistic profile the higher you drop it
the longer it flies the less accuracy it
is World War II famously these were you
get within four miles of a Target
generally that's why they had to have
thousands of aircraft dropping thousands
of bombs and that end up with carpet
bombing of areas with massive casualties
and massive infrastructure damage and
that's effectively what Russia is doing
today if we look at the next slide what
the West has done in invested
considerably in the Advent of smart
guided weapons and you see for a Joint
Strike Fighter here but the bomb here is
the same sort of thousand pound bomb
that was used in the second world war
but at the front of it you've now got a
Seeker head which is either GPS guided
or picks up laser energy and on the rear
of the weapon you can see it's got Tails
which deploy and now fly their form to
the Target not four miles accuracy now
it's four foot accuracy if you're going
to hit a Target you can have a smaller
charge smaller charge smaller casualties
smaller infrastructure incredible stuff
I'm hearing you explain all those
details so so why isn't Russia using
those more do they not have that type of
Weaponry they do but the simple answer
is corruption
um these the simple weapon costs about
two thousand pounds as soon as you put
the guidance systems it's about 10 times
as expensive undoubtedly Russia does
have some of these Munitions but their
stockpiles will be nothing like what we
expect them to be almost certainly as a
result of corruption and therefore
they've just reverted to dumb weapons
and artillery what the West is trying to
do is pump Ukraine full of modern
technology and Fire Control Radars
particularly for artillery which we
think will make a really decisive
difference in their battle ahead and try
to avoid this sort of Devastation the
key for me though is if Russia really
purports to be a global superpower then
this sort of Devastation is entirely
avoidable with the use of modern
technology weapons